Це - дрон-мінер для дистанційного замінування російських позицій.
Його створили два куми-волонтери з Івано-Франківщини.
Як виникла ідея? Подзвонили з передової знайомі і кажуть:
"Танчик приїжджає з тієї сторони і по наших позиціях відстрілюється.
Кожен Божий день у той же час у те ж саме місце".
Кажуть: "До кілометра від нас. Ми бачимо, а дістати нема чим.
Послали мінера. Мінер пішов і не повернувся".
Колеса від гіроскутера, шини - від дитячого квадроцикла, інші деталі - з Інтернету.
У звичайному гаражі чоловіки розробили цей наземний дрон вагою 40 кг,
який за хвилину може перевезти міну на 100 метрів. І подолати перешкоди на своєму шляху.
А завдяки системі скиду цей "мінер" став багаторазовим.
Систему рогатки придумав кум. Закладаєш міну, магніт.
Приїхав на позицію: джойстик натиснув, магніт скинув - міна вилетіла.
Повернувся назад, завантажив міну, і так наступну.
Усе це Володимир з Романом роблять у свій вільний час.
Крім мінувальника, вони створили наземний дрон для евакуації поранених і
велодрон для підвезення постачання.
Їх вже використовують військові на передовій.
А тепер куми працюють над новими пристроями для Сил оборони -
основою під кулемет та глушилками для дронів.
Та для усього цього їм потрібне фінансування.
З кумом у нас фактично ідеї виникають весь час. Дуже багато ідей.
Часто нема або грошей, або вільних рук. Дві в нас великі проблеми.
Ми хочемо, щоб він зробив наскільки роботу, щоб ми знали, що він завіз міни, і на тих мінах підірвався танк РФ.
І щоб нас побачило керівництво.
Щоб Валерій Федорович (Залужний) хоча би там нам лайк поставив, знаєте.
І хотілося б, аби нас побачили, розумієте.
Аби хоча би трошки в нас щось влили, аби ми далі продовжували це робити. Отака наша мрія.
Так само з квартири у Харкові почалася розробка ударного безпілотника Shoolika MK6.
Після початку повномасштабного вторгнення Євгеній допомагав ЗСУ, а потім із партнером
почав займатися військовими розробками для ЗСУ.
Ми почали будувати продукт - перший наш ударного типу БПЛА Shoolika.
Тоді він ще називався "Джура MK6", і ми його планували як цивільного призначення дрон,
який буде використовуватись як дрон, і на нього будуть ставитися якісь корисні навантаження,
системи скиду і так далі.
Потім ми пішли вже в бік того, що почали робити системи захищеного зв'язку, GPS,
камери специфічні термальні і систему корисного навантаження.
Цей дрон призначений скидати фугасно-кумулятивні снаряди і вражати техніку
та особовий склад противника вночі. Він дуже швидкий та легкий у користуванні.
Йому потрібно всього 5 хвилин, щоб він злетів, і ще плюс 2 хвилини, щоб він долетів.
Система скидування розрахована на 4 снаряди, вона почергово їх скидає.
Тобто пілот після кожного скиду може робити поправки по вітру або по ще якихось умовах.
І це йому дозволяє більш точно скидати.
Тобто якщо ми кидаємо перший снаряд, бачимо, що ми 3 метри від цілі,
то ми другий кидаємо чітко в ціль. А я вам скажу, трьох снарядів вистачить,
щоб там нормально біди наробити.
Усі модулі за потреби можна легко замінити. А замість великого наземного комплекса -
пульт дистанційного керування і свій модуль зв'язку.
Shoolika MK6 версія X може летіти від 7 до 10 км, або якщо це політ по часу, то це близько 30 хвилин.
Має захищений радіо- та телеметричний канал, захищений модуль зв'язку GNSS, тобто GPS, і відеосигнал.
Має камеру термальну, тільки термальну на цьому дроні.
Можлива ще опція термальна плюс денна камера.
Це двосенсорна камера, яку в принципі теж можна поставити на цю ж систему.
Працює на висоті від 150 до 250 метрів.
Це стабільна висота для роботи з такою камерою.
Точність влучання чи кучність влучання близько 1-2 квадратних метрів з висоти 150 метрів.
А сам дрон - досить РЕБостійкий.
Ми дуже сильно заморочувалися над зв'язком. Тобто навіть якщо, те, що ви говорили про РЕБ,
навіть якщо нам вибивають супутники, пілот може вручну тримати дрон, позиціонувати його і довести його назад
або прийняти рішення продовжити місію.
Третій блок нашої розробки - це GNSS-приймач, який ми прошиваємо самі і робимо фільтр,
який відслідковує задавлення GPS-сигналу. Тобто якщо дрон відчуває задавлення GPS-сигналу,
то програмне забезпечення, яке на борту нашого ресівера, відслідковує це і перемикає на інший діапазон.
Тобто антена підтримує 5 діапазонів і будь-який з цих 5 діапазонів повинен працювати.
Якщо все ж таки станеться так, що всі 5 діапазонів заглушать,
то звичайно дрон не зможе орієнтуватися в просторі.
У компанії кажуть: готові працювати і постачати сотні таких ударних дронів на передову -
лише б були кошти та замовлення від держави. Зараз компанія подала документи на сертифікацію дронів
і в подальшому прагне отримати оборонне замовлення.
Та для цього треба пройти 12 кіл бюрократичного пекла, кажуть розробники.
Мета - щоб у військових не було головного болю відносно того, що збирати кошти.
Щоб держава закупила сотні, тисячі Shoolik, і щоб це у військові частини просто потрапило.
Тому що зараз замість того, щоб команда Skylab думала про продукт, про вдосконалення, про РНД стадії,
про якісь блоки, про випробування, щоб їздила за кордон, спілкувалася з військовими,
які мають ліпші системи зв'язку, GNSS і так далі, і держава була спроможна закупити це все.
Ми поставили це, масово поставили і серійно ми б змогли задовольнити 150 плюс на рік державу,
а саме військовим дроном Shoolikа.
Спростити цей процес взявся кластер Brave1 - перший кластер для розвитку технологій в оборонній галузі.
Це державний проєкт, заснований Мінцифри, Міноборони, Генштабом, РНБО, Мінекономіки та Мінстратегпром.
Ця платформа покликана об’єднати розробників військових технологій з компаніями, державою та армією.
Щоб ці розробки якомога швидше могли з’явитися на полі бою.
Сьогодні держава зацікавлена в тому, щоб таких оборонних технологій з'являлося дуже багато, тому ми розуміємо,
що ці гроші якраз допомагають виробникам зробити перший прототип, його протестувати,
довести його ефективність. І далі після цього легше вже всім,
або, особливо коли вже є допуск до експлуатації і підтвердження документальне,
то тоді вже простіше набагато йти з цим виробником до міністра техпрому і з ними говорити про масштабування,
або з ними йти до інших великих виробників, які шукають собі партнерів,
або шукати інших просто виробничих потужностей для масштабування цього продукту - це вже не питання.
Тобто історія в тому, що цей грант має якраз допомогти зробити перший МВП,
який продемонструє свою ефективність, який буде погоджений,
буде затверджено Генеральним штабом та Міноборони, Силами безпеки і оборони.
SkyLab подалася і виграла грант на 25 тисяч доларів.
Але ця сума - крапля в морі, кажуть розробники.
Адже створення одного винаходу обійшлося їм у десятки разів дорожче.
Ці гроші нам потрібні для однієї мети - ми хочемо замінити деякі модулі,
наприклад, модулі GNSS-приймача на інші, вони коштують гроші.
Тобто ці модулі вже військового призначення, а не цивільного, який ми доробляємо,
який ми пишемо прошивку і самі робимо. Ці модулі вже пройшли перевірку в країнах Альянсу.
Ми хочемо поставити ці модулі і спробувати використати дрон на більш потужному РЕБі,
на якому зараз GNSS-приймач не витримує.
На грант може податися будь-яка людина, стартап чи компанія, яка розробила зброю чи техніку для армії.
Там розробка отримає військову експертизу від Генштабу.
Генштаб визначив 12 пріоритетних напрямків:
системи розвідки, артилерія, розмінування, управління боєм, медичне забезпечення та інші.
Серед них два основних: наземні роботизовані комплекси і РЕБ та РЕР системи зв’язку.
Фокус - це наземні роботизовані комплекси, на це є велика потреба.
Ми бачимо вже сьогодні у нас на платформі за 3,5 місяці проєкту
зареєструвалося у нас вже більше 400 команд, і серед тих 70 команд,
які безпосередньо розробляють НРК.
І у нас вже перші такі комплекси проходять допуск до експлуатації, кодифікації НАТО.
Тобто вони вже можуть дуже швидко вийти на лінії фронту, їх там вже дуже чекають.
І друга історія - це все, що стосується РЕБ і РЕР систем з'язку,
тому що це знов-таки, по-перше, захист, і захист наших людей, і це, умовно кажучи,
захист наших дронів і нашої техніки, яка летить на ту сторону.
Крім того, ми знаємо, що вороги, насправді, дуже потужні є у своїх системах РЕБ.
Добре знається на радіоелектронній боротьбі компанія Піранья Тех,
яка ще з 2014 року займається системами пригнічення зв’язку.
Вони розробили потужні антидронові рушниці,
комплекси для захисту техніки та установки для пригнічення безпілотників.
А купують їхнє обладнання у 25-ти країнах світу.
В даному випадку це так званий прилад для створення купола
за рахунок кругових антен вертикальної поляризації.
Він може працювати як з рушницею такою, так і з антенами.
Це одна з версій такої самої рушниці, просто в менших розмірах сам блок.
Ця рушниця так само може працювати з такими ж самими антенами без рушниці.
Коли вона їде, можна поставити цей рюкзак у машину
і буде створений купол, який дозволить зменшити втрати від FPV-дронів та скидів.
150-200 метрів.
Одразу тестуємо, як вона працює.
Зараз включаємо рушницю.
Коли ми розуміємо, що є дрон, або ми його бачимо,
включаємо антидронову рушницю, включається програма, перевіряє готовність каналів.
Після цього ми включаємо подавлення.
Якщо включаємо подавлення навігації,
то в нас включається і подавлення частоти, на яких літають FPV-дрони.
Також тут працює і 2, 4, і 5. І чекаємо, дивимося, де може бути дрон.
Для того, щоб відпрацювати, закрити йому навігацію і управління.
Оскільки жарко, вентилятори вже працюють,
вони охолоджують систему, вона не нагрівається.
Ось там знаходиться дрон, його видно.
Дія рушниці спрямована для переривання зв'язку дрона з оператором -
щоб він не міг коригувати чи наводити вогонь.
Супутники зникли. Керування 3 є.
GPS втратили. Керування поки ще є.
Тобто зараз було придушення каналів керування і GPS,
завдяки чому пілот втрачає спочатку орієнтацію по супутниках,
а потім втрачає канали керування.
Тобто дрон переходить в режим повернення додому,
якщо воно є таке налаштування, або просто зависає на місці, тому що на фронті,
наприклад, не використовується така функція.
Часто дрон зависає, потім з часом знижується вниз
і просто завдяки тому, що розряджається акумулятор, втрачається.
А ось такі великі системи здатні захистити від безпілотників
у межах двадцяти кілометрів, кажуть розробники.
Це мобільна система, яка працює в рамках батальйону, бригади,
тобто вона працює на дальностях до 20 км.
І вона працює, в основному, по безпілотних літальних апаратах,
по розвідниках. Ось це її основна функція.
Тому вона використовується для прикриття повітряного простору
від великих БПЛА - "Орланів", такого типу.
Усю цю продукцію виготовляють в Україні.
Військові легко можуть користуватися і ремонтувати таку техніку.
Та фактичних замовлень від держави поки немає.
Фактичних замовлень - це коли Міністерство оборони напряму
заключає договір і закуповує те обладнання, яке їм необхідне.
На сьогоднішній день поки що потреба не сформована.
Тобто немає потреби, немає замовлення, немає коштів.
Тобто всі фактичні закупівлі радіоелектронного обладнання, скажімо так, 60% чи може 70%,
тому що є там компанії, які все-таки до війни стали на озброєння,
і в них є державне замовлення. Всі інші, але я так розумію,
його не зовсім вистачає, всі інші, що включилися в цю роботу,
фактично вони працюють на власних коштах.
Розробники сподіваються, що зі створенням defense-tech площадки
вони зможуть краще зрозуміти потреби Міноборони, отримати оборонне замовлення
та фінансування на нові, покращені взірці та їхнє випробування.
Так, звичайно, там поки що невеликі суми.
Говорять про те, що є якісь інвестори, які готові будуть потім вкладати кошти в ті взірці,
які пройдуть випробування в Міністерстві оборони.
Ну, будемо надіятися, що це правда.
Адже основна мета кожного із розробників -
допомогти армії та пришвидшити
перемогу України.